Earlier this year, I saw the movie Trading Places again on Netflix and I thought, I've seen this movie over and over again, but I've never really understood what happens on the trading floor at the end of the movie. And one of the great things about working in public radio is that it's a pretty small world. So, I've met Robert Smith before and so I just wrote him at Planet Money and I said, I want to do a story where you help explain the economics of trading places to me. And for everyone else like me who also doesn't quite get it, but loves the movie but doesn't
今年早些时候，我在 Netflix 上又看了一遍电影《颠倒乾坤》，我想，这部电影我已经看过无数遍了，但我从来没有真正搞懂过电影结尾时交易大厅里到底发生了什么。而做公共广播的一大好处就是，这个圈子其实非常小。所以，我以前就认识罗伯特·史密斯，于是我就给“金钱星球”栏目（Planet Money）给他写了封信，我说，我想做一个节目，让你帮我解释一下《颠倒乾坤》背后的经济学。为了像我这样也并不是完全搞懂，但又非常喜欢这部电影的人，但并没有完全搞懂的其他人。
quite get it. And so I wanted to share that story with you guys. It was so much fun working with them. And I really liked the story that came out. Back in the 1980s, Lewis Winthrop III was a big deal in the world of future trading. He worked at a fancy firm in Philadelphia, and this guy knew commodities. Worked values. I have a hunch something very exciting is going to happen in the port fairly marked this morning.
完全搞懂。所以我想把这个故事分享给大家。和他们合作非常开心。我真的很喜欢最后出来的这个故事。在上世纪80年代，小路易斯·温索普在期货交易界可是个大人物。他在费城一家高级公司工作，而且这家伙对大宗商品了如指掌。工作价值。我有种预感，今天早上港口肯定会有非常激动人心的事发生。
Lewis was the best. He was about to get married in the future looked bright. We are going to make a great couple. We're going to have a great life. Until his bosses ran off and Mortimer Duke took all of that away from him. And so begins the great parable about what happens when the rich become poor, the poor become rich, and a con man inherits the earth. The movie is trading places.
路易斯是最棒的。他即将结婚，未来一片光明。我们将成为绝配。我们将过上美好的生活。直到他的老板们卷铺逃跑，莫蒂默·杜克夺走了他的一切。关于富人变穷、穷人变富以及骗子赢得世界时会发生什么的一部伟大寓言就这样拉开了序幕。这部电影就是《颠倒乾坤》。
Hello and welcome planet money, I'm Robert Smith. And I'm Roman Mars. Look good, Roman. Feeling good, Robert. Roman Mars is the host of the podcast, 99% Invisible. It's about all things design and architecture. And he's on planet money today because he had an actual question for us about this movie.
你好，欢迎收听“金钱星球”，我是罗伯特·史密斯。我是罗曼·马斯。看起来气色不错，罗曼。感觉很好，罗曼。罗曼·马斯是播客节目《99%无形》的主持人。这个节目探讨的是有关设计和建筑的一切。他今天来到“金钱星球”，是因为他关于这部电影有一个真正的问题要问我们。
Well, I love this movie. I saw it when I was way, way too young. I was probably nine or 10. And I just wanted to know, is this the most sophisticated depiction of the inner workings of a financial market in the history of cinema? That is the perfect question for us, Roman Mars, because we have the ability and we shall bring in
嗯，我很喜欢这部电影。我第一次看的时候年龄实在太小了。我大概九、十岁吧。我只是想知道，这难道不是电影史上对金融市场内部运作最老练、最高明的描绘吗？罗曼·马斯，这绝对是我们梦寐以求的绝妙问题，因为我们有能力，而且我们也将请来
an entire panel of experts in the commodities and futures trading world to fact check this movie. Today, on Planet Money, what the movie trading places can teach you about financial markets. And I know this is a particular interest to you, Roman. We are finally going to explain one of the great enduring mysteries. What the hell actually happened
一整支由大宗商品和期货交易界专家组成的专家团来对这部电影进行事实核查。今天在“金钱星球”上，电影《颠倒乾坤》能教给你哪些关于金融市场的知识。我知道你对这个特别感兴趣，罗曼。我们终于要解释一个经久不衰的巨大谜团了。到底发生了什么鬼
at the end of this crazy movie? Oh, I definitely need that. So if it's been a while since you've seen trading places, everything is going really well for Lewis Winthorpe until his bosses they have an argument about nature versus nurture and the evil Randolph Duke bets his maybe even slightly more evil brother, Mortimer Duke, that he can take away Lewis's job, and his fiance, and his home, and his friends, and they can turn him into a criminal. While at the same time, the Duke brothers take a con man from the street, named Billy Ray
这部疯狂电影的结局到底是怎么回事？哦，我绝对需要这个。所以，如果你已经很久没看过《颠倒乾坤》了，路易斯·温索普原本一切都顺风顺水，直到他的老板们为了先天与后天哪个更重要争论不休，邪恶的兰道夫·杜克跟他的可能甚至还要更邪恶的弟弟莫蒂默·杜克打赌，说他能夺走路易斯的职位、未婚夫、家、朋友，并把路易斯变成一个罪犯。与此同时，杜克兄弟从街头找来了一个名叫比利·雷·
Valentine, he's played by Eddie Murphy. And they give him Louis's entire life, his job, his home, his butler, and they try to turn him into a hot shot commodities broker. It's kind of a modern day twist on Prince and the Pomer. Eventually the two guinea pigs they find each other. And Louis and Billy Ray conspire to get back at the dukes and they make a brilliant plan to make themselves really rich and put the duke brothers in the poor house at the same time. It is a crazy, complicated plan that involves futures trading on commodities and cornering the market and frozen, concentrated, orange juice. Right there, that's my first question.
瓦伦丁的骗子，这个角色由艾迪·墨菲饰演。他们把路易斯的一切都给了他：工作、房子、管家，并试图把他培养成一个叱咤风云的大宗商品经纪人。这有点像是现代版的《王子与乞丐》。最终，这两个试验品相遇了。路易斯和比利·雷密谋向杜克兄弟复仇，他们制订了一个绝妙的计划，既能让自己暴富，同时又能让杜克兄弟倾家荡产。这是一个疯狂、复杂的计划，涉及大宗商品的期货交易、操纵市场以及冷冻浓缩橙汁。看，这就是我的第一个问题。
Frozen, concentrated, orange juice is central to the movie. And when I first saw it, I totally thought that was made up as a commodity, just to be funny. In the real world, my thinking was, you would just trade oranges. Sure, yeah. Who would spend their lives trading little cans of frozen concentrated orange juice? I found somebody, this guy. My name is Tom Pironis and I'm a commodity trader. I'm just coming back from the floor of the New York Mercantile Exchange where I spent the last four hours buying and selling orange juice options in futures. It's real! It's totally real! This guy does it all day long!
冷冻浓缩橙汁是这部电影的核心。我第一次看的时候，完全以为那是为了好玩而凭空捏造的一种大宗商品。在现实世界中，我的想法是，大家只会交易橙子。当然，是的。谁会花一辈子去交易一罐罐小小的冷冻浓缩橙汁呢？我还真找到了一位，就是这家伙。我叫汤姆·皮罗尼斯，是一名大宗商品交易员。我刚从纽约商业交易所的交易大厅回来，过去四个小时里，我一直在买卖橙汁期权和期货。这是真的！完全是真的！这家伙整天都在干这个！
So Tom Perronis, he's going to be our first experts on all things frozen and all things orange. And we're being our second expert in just a moment. But we're going to use both of them to fact check this premise that you had, Roman, that trading places basically could be a university level course in finance and commodities. And as someone who explains economics for a living, I mean, this is my job. I take my hat off to the writers of this movie. Just listen to this scene. The Duke Brothers in the scene lead Eddie Murphy,
所以，汤姆·佩罗尼斯将成为我们关于一切冷冻和橙子相关事宜的第一位专家。我们稍后还会请出第二位专家。但我们将借助他们俩来验证你刚才提出的那个前提，罗曼，即《颠倒乾坤》基本上可以作为一门大学水平的金融和大宗商品课程。作为一名以解释经济学为生的人，我的意思是，这就是我的工作。我对这部电影的编剧佩服得五体投地。听听这场戏就知道了。戏里的杜克兄弟把艾迪·墨菲，
Billy Ray Valentine, to a table. And set on that table is a beautiful breakfast. No thanks, guys. They're already at breakfast this morning. This is not a meal, Valentine. We are here to try to explain to you what it is we do here. We are commodities brokers, William. Now, what are commodities?
比利·雷·瓦伦丁带到一张桌子前。桌上摆着一顿丰盛的早餐。不用了，各位。他们今天早上已经吃过早饭了。这不是一顿饭，瓦伦丁。我们来这里，是想向你解释我们平时在这里做什么。我们是大宗商品经纪人，威廉。那么，什么叫大宗商品？
Commodities are agricultural products, like coffee that you had for breakfast, wheat, which is used to make bread, pork bellies, which is used to make bacon, which you might find in a bacon and lettuce and tomato sandwich. At this point, anywhere if he just to make bacon, which you might find in a bacon and let us into made of sandwich? At this point, anywhere if he just deadpans right into the camera, I suspect that sometimes point at money listeners feel the same way when we're explaining this to them. And then there are other commodities like frozen orange juice and gold. Of course gold doesn't grow on trees like oranges. Clear so far?
大宗商品是指农产品，比如你早餐喝的咖啡、用来做面包的小麦、用来做培根的猪肚肉——你可能会在培根生菜西红柿三明治里吃到它。此时此刻，只要他对着镜头面无表情地说，我猜有时候“金钱星球”的听众在我们向他们解释这些时也有同感。除此之外，还有其他大宗商品，比如冷冻橙汁和黄金。当然，黄金可不像橙子那样长在树上。到现在为止都清楚吗？
Yeah. And reviewing the movie they really really did a good job. I mean someone on that team knew what they were doing. This is our second expert Bob Lassendrello. He's a commodities trader in Chicago. He used to trade cattle futures like Roman, you might find in a roast beef, cheddar, and tomato sandwich. Of course, if you watch that scene, you might think that these guys trade in physical things, the physical things that you see on the table, the bacon, the wheat, the cans of orange juice. But Tom Perone says that in the orange juice market, that's not quite right. Yeah, it's definitely not stored just in little cans. Yeah, they probably have large refrigerator type units for them.
嗯。回顾这部电影，他们真的做得非常出色。我是说，那个团队里绝对有人是行家。这是我们的第二位专家鲍勃·拉森德雷洛。他是芝加哥的一名大宗商品交易员。他过去常常交易活牛期货——就像罗曼你可能会在烤牛肉切达奶酪番茄三明治里吃到的那样。当然，如果你看了那一幕，你可能会觉得这些人交易的是实体东西，也就是你在桌子上看到的那些实体东西：培根、小麦、一罐罐的橙汁。但汤姆·佩罗尼斯说，在橙汁市场上，情况并非如此。是的，它绝对不仅仅是储存在小罐子里。是的，他们可能会有大型的冷冻设备。
What do you mean, probably? You buy and sell this stuff. You have no idea what it looks like? No. And as a matter of fact, if you trade agricultural commodities, most commodity traders go their whole careers without ever seeing the physical product. I mean, I used to trade pork bellies and live hogs. And I wouldn't know a pork belly if it dropped on the table here.
什么叫“可能”？你天天买卖这东西，竟然不知道它长什么样？不清楚。事实上，如果你交易的是农产品，大多数大宗商品交易员职业生涯的大部分时间里，甚至连见都没见过实物。我的意思是，我以前做过猪肚和活猪的交易。就算把一块猪肚扔在这个桌子上，我都认不出来。
Yeah, the reason Tom Peronis wouldn't recognize a pork belly on the table is because people like him who do this in real life are trading contracts on pork bellies. Or technically, the future promise to deliver a certain amount of pork bellies at a certain time at a certain price. What it really is, it's a wager. It's a bet on whether you think something is going to go up or down in price. And Mortimer and Randolph Duke in the movie, they make money whether it goes up or down. The good part, William, is that no matter whether our clients make money or lose money, Duke and Duke get the commissions.
对，汤姆·佩罗尼斯之所以在桌上认不出猪肚，是因为像他这样在现实生活中从事这行的人，交易的其实是猪肚的合同。或者严格来说，是未来在某个时间、以某个价格交付一定数量猪肚的承诺。说白了，这就是一场豪赌。这是一场赌注，赌你认为某种东西的价格会上涨还是下跌。而在电影里，莫蒂默和兰道夫·杜克无论价格涨跌都能赚钱。好的一点是，威廉，无论我们的客户是赚钱还是赔钱，杜克父子都能拿到佣金。
Well, what do you think, Valentine? Well, it sounds to me like you guys are couple of bookies. I told you he'd understand. I know this whole contract's thing may seem theoretical, but the bets are based on an actual contract about an actual real thing. The trade has just hold the contract for just a few minutes or a few days, enough time to make a little money. But before the contract expires and the actual good has to be delivered,
那么，你觉得怎么样，瓦伦丁？嗯，在我看来，你们俩就像是一对开盘口的庄家。我早就说过他能懂。我知道所有这些合同的事情可能看起来很抽象，但赌注是基于关于某个实际事物的实际合同。交易员持有合同的时间只有短短几分钟或几天，只要时间够赚点小钱就行。但在合同到期、必须交付实际货物之前，
that trader needs to unload the contract, needs to sell to someone who actually wants the thing underneath the contract, who actually wants the oranges, who wants the bacon, who wants the live cows. Remember, that's what Bob Lassen-Drell had traded in, live cattle futures. He didn't want a cow. He just wanted to make a bet on the future prices of cows.
那名交易员必须脱手这份合同，必须把它卖给真正想要合同背后那个实体的人，也就是真正想要橙子、想要培根、想要活牛的人。记住，那正是鲍勃·拉森德雷洛曾经交易过的品种——活牛期货。他其实并不想要一头牛。他只是想对牛的未来价格下注。
But once Bob did screw up. Did you ever receive an actual cow? Oh boy, did I. Did you realize it? Yeah, not a cow, 40 of them, and more than 40. You made a mistake. Yes. You made a mistake. Yes. You made a mistake and somebody called you on the phone
但鲍勃确实也搞砸过一次。你真的收到过一头真正的牛吗？哦，天哪，我收到了。你当时意识到了吗？对，不是一头牛，是40头，甚至不止40头。你犯了个错误。是的。你犯了个错误。是的。你犯了个错误，然后有人打电话给你
and just said, we have cattle here for you. Were they on a truck or something? Oh, yeah. Or they're in the pen. They're actually off the truck and in the pen. It's what it is. And so when the guys in the East St. Louis stockyards found out that a futures trader took delivery on some cattle,
对你说，我们这里有你的牛。它们是用卡车运来的还是怎么着？哦，对。或者它们就在围栏里。它们确实是从卡车上卸下来，关在围栏里的。就是这样。所以，当东圣路易斯牲畜市场的那些人发现一个期货交易员竟然真的接收了一批牛时，
they generally aren't super helpful about how they don't really give you a hand letting you sell them. They kind of stick you with some extra fees and you know they don't like us guys, they didn't at the time like us guys sort of meddling in their world. Now back to the movie, Billy Ray Valentine, who's now called William Valentine by the dukes, is learning this commodity's world. And it turns out he has some talent for it, because it's not just about knowing the facts and the figures of the contracts and the commodities. A lot of it is about knowing psychology. Tell me just why you think the price of pork belly is going down, William?
他们通常不会怎么帮忙，不会搭把手让你把它们卖掉。他们反而会给你塞一些额外的费用，而且你知道的，他们不喜欢我们这些人，当时他们就不喜欢我们这些人在他们的世界里瞎掺和。现在回到电影中，比利·雷·瓦伦丁——现在被杜克兄弟叫做威廉·瓦伦丁——正在学习这个大宗商品的世界。事实证明，他在这一行很有天赋，因为这不仅仅是了解合同和大宗商品的各项事实和数据。很大程度上，这考验的是对心理的把控。你告诉我，威廉，你为什么觉得猪肚的价格会下跌？
It's Christmas time, everybody's up tight. Could we please buy now, Randolph? Right, but if you want to lose money, go ahead. What are you trying to say, William? Okay, park belly prices have been dropping all morning, which means everybody sitting in the office and they waiting for me hit rock bottom so they can buy cheap and go long.
现在是圣诞节，大家心里都很紧张。兰道夫，我们现在能买进吗？对，但如果你想赔钱的话，尽管买好了。你这话是什么意思，威廉？好吧，猪肚价格整个早上一直在跌，这意味着每个人都坐在办公室里，等着我跌到谷底，好让他们抄底并做多。
So people are on the park belly contracts are going bad. They're thinking, hey, we losing all our damn money and Christmas is around the corner and I ain't got no money to buy my son to GI Joe with the Kung Fu grip, okay? And my wife ain't gonna make love to me and I ain't got no money to buy my son to GI Joe with the Kung Fu grip, okay? And my wife ain't gonna make love to me because I ain't got no money, right? So they sit there and they panic
所以人们在猪肚合同上要惨了。他们心想，天哪，我们把所有的钱都亏光了，圣诞节就在眼前，我连给我儿子买个带功夫抓握动作的特种部队玩具（GI Joe）的钱都没有，好吗？我老婆也不会跟我亲热了，因为我连给我儿子买个带功夫抓握动作的特种部队玩具的钱都没有，好吗？我老婆也不会跟我亲热了，因为我没钱，对吧？所以他们坐在那里开始恐慌
and they scream and sell, sell! Cause they don't wanna lose all their money, right? They are their panic right now. I can feel it, they are their panic. They're looking at it. He's right, Mortimer, my God, look at that. I wait till you get to about 64 then I'd buy. You have cleared out all the suckers, buy them.
然后尖叫着“卖出，卖出！”因为他们不想把所有的钱都亏光，对吧？他们现在恐慌了。我能感觉得到，他们正处在恐慌之中。他们正盯着看呢。他说得对，莫蒂默，天哪，你看那个。我打算等到跌到64左右再买。你们已经把这群笨蛋全套牢了，买进！
Of course, Billy Ray Valentine makes them a ton of money. But Bob Lesson Drellau has the small quibble with this scene. He says people don't really declare a particular price for a commodity. No one ever says it's going to 64. They don't really know exactly. But people make bets on whether things just go up and down. Is that right to people just have absolutely, absolutely?
当然，比利·雷·瓦伦丁让他们大赚了一笔。但鲍勃·拉森德雷洛对这一幕有个小小的微词。他说，人们在现实中其实并不会为一个大宗商品标出一个具体的价格。没有人会说它会跌到64。他们其实并不确切知道。但人们会根据价格是涨是跌来下注。是这样吗？人们会完全、百分之百地确定吗？
Absolutely. What would happen is, you know, the guys who would just, you'd be standing around and you'd have to start to have a feeling that the market was going to go up or down and then you would trade accordingly. It's sort of like your brain processing all this information ends up manifesting itself as what's called a feel, and then you buy or you sell accordingly. So far, according to our experts, the movie trading places is nailing it. They have this commodities
完全确定。通常的情况是，你知道的，大家就站在那里，然后你开始有一种感觉，觉得市场要涨还是要跌，接着你就会据此进行交易。这有点像你的大脑处理了所有这些信息，最终表现为一种所谓的“盘感”，然后你据此进行买入或卖出。到目前为止，根据我们的专家所说，《颠倒乾坤》这部电影表现得堪称完美。他们把大宗商品
thing down pat. But then it gets a little Hollywood. Lewis Winthrop, our down and out rich boy, he teems up with his former butler and a prostitute with a heart of gold. We did not fact check that one. You don't even need to. Yeah, it's a given. Exactly. Billy Ray, the con man, turned trading savant, figures out, wait a minute, I've been played. And he joins up with Winthrop and they catch this plan
这一套摸得透透的。但接下来剧情就变得有点好莱坞化了。路易斯·温索普，我们那个落魄的富家子弟，和他的前管家以及一个心地善良的妓女联手了。我们没有对这一情节进行事实核查。你甚至不需要核查。对，这是理所当然的。没错。比利·雷，那个由骗子转变为交易天才的家伙，突然反应过来：等等，我被耍了。于是他加入了温索普的阵营，他们精心策划了一个计划，
to make millions of dollars and bankrupt the dukes. And it's the end of the movie where I have my biggest questions. When I was a kid, I saw it and I know that something important is happening on the trading floor at the end, that the underdogs win, they get rich, the dukes go bankrupt. But I didn't really understand it. And when I watch it again, the funny thing is I still don't really understand it as an adult.
要赚几百万美元并让杜克兄弟破产。而正是在电影的结尾，我产生了最大的疑问。小时候我看的时候就知道了，结尾时交易大厅里正在发生一件大事，弱者赢了，他们发了财，而杜克兄弟破产了。但我当时并没有真正看懂。等我再次重温时，搞笑的是，作为一个成年人，我其实还是没完全看懂。
And before I joined PlayDab, I don't think I would have got to eat there. But I have now studied this movie over again. We've talked to the experts and we are going to break this thing down. Because, Roman, if you were paying attention, this movie has already taught you everything you need to know about commodities and how to corner the market. Now, remember the orange juice that was in the breakfast scene? Yes. Frozen Concentrated Orange Juice. Okay.
而且在我加入“金钱星球”之前，我想我是绝对弄不懂的。但我现在已经把这部电影反反复复研究透了。我们采访了专家，接下来我们要把这一段彻底拆解。因为，罗曼，如果你刚才有认真听的话，这部电影其实已经把你需要了解的关于大宗商品以及如何操纵市场的一切知识都教给你了。现在，还记得早餐那场戏里的橙汁吗？记得。冷冻浓缩橙汁。好的。
So in the movie The Duke Brothers have bribed a guy to get an advance copy of the, never happens in movies, an advance copy of the USDA Orange Crop Report, which is a totally real thing. These crop reports come out every month. They tell you how much of a commodity is out there. Now, this, if they know it in advance, how many oranges are out there, they will then know whether the price is going to go up or down. And that part I understand, the crop report is going to say that the supply of oranges
所以在电影里，杜克兄弟买通了一个人，提前拿到了——这在电影里是绝对不会发生的——美国农业部橙子收成报告的抢先版，而这在现实中是完全存在的。这些农作物报告每个月都会发布。它们会告诉你某种大宗商品目前的产量有多少。现在，如果他们提前知道了橙子的产量是多少，他们就能知道价格会上涨还是下跌。这部分我懂，农作物报告将显示橙子的供应量
is fine, that there's plenty of good, cheap orange juice to go around. Yeah, it's a normal day in the market, except our heroes are going to trick the Duke brothers. They're going to pull the old switcheroo. So they slip the brothers a fake crop report. A report that says, oh my God, there was this terrible frost in Florida, lots of dead oranges. The fake report would make any savvy trader know that the price of orange juice
很正常，市面上会有大量物美价廉的橙汁供应。是的，这本该是市场上普通的一天，但我们的主角们打算捉弄一下杜克兄弟。他们要玩个偷梁换柱的花招。于是他们偷偷塞给杜克兄弟一份假的农作物报告。一份声称“天哪，佛罗里达州发生了可怕的寒灾，大量橙子被冻死”的报告。这份假报告会让任何精明的交易员都意识到，橙汁的价格
is going to go through the roof. So the Duke brothers think that the supplies low and the price is going to go up. And they are willing to bet everything on it. And they are so wrong. They are so wrong. Our heroes, Billy Ray Valentine and Louis Winthorpe, that's the former trader who got screwed by the dukes,
马上要一飞冲天了。所以杜克兄弟以为供应量很低，价格会上涨。他们愿意为此赌上一切。而他们大错特错了。错得离谱。我们的主角比利·雷·瓦伦丁和路易斯·温索普——也就是那个被杜克兄弟坑惨了的前交易员，
they know the truth. They know that the orange supply is fine. And they know that the price is going to go down. So let's bring back our OJ expert, Tom Peronis, and we're going to watch this final scene together and get a play by play. Our heroes with their stolen insider information, our heroes are striding out onto the trading floor of the New York Mercantile Exchange. There's my old place of employment. That's the World Trade Center. Yeah and that's I had an office in that building right there. That's that's where the exchange was.
他们知道真相。他们知道橙子的供应量根本没问题。他们知道价格马上要下跌了。所以，让我们请回我们的橙汁专家汤姆·皮罗尼斯，我们一起来看这最后的高潮戏，并做个实况解说。我们的主角带着他们偷来的内幕消息，大步走上了纽约商业交易所的交易大厅。那是我以前工作的地方。那是世贸中心。对，我在那栋楼里有过办公室。交易所就在那里。
Inside, you see all the traders and their ugly vests gathering on this large floor staring up at the clock. And it's pandemonium. Tom says this is exactly what it was like before computers. Maybe not quite so many people excited about frozen orange juice, but still does make me nostalgic for floor-based trading. Now once again, Roman, you gotta keep all these things in your head if this gonna make sense. The Duke brothers think there's gonna be a shortage of oranges because according to their fake crop report, the harvest will be bad, so prices should go up. They tell their guy, their floor trader.
走进去，你可以看到所有的交易员和他们丑陋的马甲汇聚在这个巨大的大厅里，抬头盯着时钟。一片混乱。汤姆说，这完全就是电脑普及之前的真实写照。也许没有那么多人对冷冻浓缩橙汁这么狂热，但这确实让我对这种基于交易大厅的交易充满怀念。好了，罗曼，你必须再次把所有这些事情在脑子里理清楚，这样这一切才说得通。杜克兄弟认为橙子会短缺，因为根据他们的假农作物报告，收成会很糟糕，所以价格应该上涨。他们告诉他们的代理人，也就是交易大厅里的经纪人。
We want you to buy as much OJ as you can, the instant trading starts. Don't worry if the price starts going up, just keep buying. The price starts at $1.2 cents a pound, and as the Duke brothers buy, the price starts to go up and up. They are bidding up the price of orange juice. And the rest of the traders start to notice. Hey, hey, the dukes are trying to corner the market. I know something. I can feel it.
我们希望你一开盘就尽可能多地买进橙汁。别担心价格开始上涨，只管一直买。开盘价是每磅1.02美元，随着杜克兄弟不断买入，价格开始一路上涨。他们在把橙汁价格往高处抬。其他的交易员也开始注意到这一点。嘿，嘿，杜克兄弟在企图操纵市场。我知道有内幕。我能感觉得到。
Let's get in on it. OK, I got to tell you here, Roman, the actor who says, they know something. I can feel it. That is Jack Davidson, father of Planned Money's very old Adam Davidson. And as Adam will say is it really is the most critical line in the entire movie delivered by his father. That's amazing. But it is actually important
我们也赶紧入场吧。好吧，我得跟你说个事，罗曼，那个台词是“我知道有内幕。我能感觉得到”的演员，就是杰克·戴维森，“金钱星球”元老亚当·戴维森的父亲。正如亚当所说，这确实是整部电影中最关键的一句台词，由他的父亲倾情奉献。太神奇了。但这对于剧情来说确实至关重要，
for the plot because everyone starts to buy oranges. The price goes higher and higher at $10, $20, $1.30. Everyone now thinks there is an orange shortage. The only problem is, of course, we know as the audience that it's based on a lot. So, Billy Ray Valentine, Louis Winthrop, stand quietly in the madness of the trading floor around them. They know the price is too high. They know it's getting higher, and they know it's about to collapse.
因为每个人都开始疯狂买入橙子。价格越炒越高：1.10美元、1.20美元、1.30美元。现在每个人都觉得橙子要短缺了。唯一的问题是，当然，我们作为观众知道这一切都是基于一个骗局。所以，比利·雷·瓦伦丁和路易斯·温索普静静地站在周围疯狂的交易大厅里。他们知道价格已经高得离谱了。他们知道价格还在继续飙升，而且他们知道价格马上就要崩盘了。
And so, they wanna do, little trick, they have heard of, called short selling. They wanna sell orange juice while the price is high. So when the price hits 142, Dan Acroid looks up, and he screams, Sound down and April the 142! Oh! And I think this is a good candidate
所以，他们想使出一个他们听说过的小把戏，叫做卖空。他们想趁价格高的时候把橙汁卖掉。所以当价格飙升到1.42美元时，丹·艾克罗伊德抬起头，尖叫道：“以1.42美元卖出30手四月期货！”哦！我觉得这绝对可以竞争
for the second most important line of the movie with all respect to Jack Davidson. And I totally missed it. I've rewatched that movie again and again. I have no idea what he says there, what Dan Acroix says there. So we had Tom explain. He's selling 30 April, a 142. What's he doing?
电影中第二重要的台词，向杰克·戴维森致敬。而我当时完全没听出来。这部电影我反反复复看了好多遍。我根本不知道他在那儿喊了什么，丹·艾克罗伊德到底说了什么。所以我们请汤姆来解释一下。他在以1.42美元的价格卖出30手四月期货。他在干什么？
He's selling 30 futures contracts at a price of 142 per pound. And there's kind of a feeding frenzy driving the market higher. But these guys have what they believe is the real information and they're selling into that rally. So selling into the rally means you think the price is going to go down. Yes. All right, so I'm starting to get this. Billy Ray and Lewis, they're selling high. They're selling orange juice to everyone who thinks that is going to go even higher than
他在以每磅1.42美元的价格卖出30份期货合约。当时市场正处于一种疯狂抢购的狂热中，推高了市场行情。但这些人掌握着他们坚信是真实的信息，他们正在趁着这波上涨行情反向卖出。所以“在涨势中卖出”意味着你认为价格要下跌。是的。好吧，那我开始明白了。比利·雷和路易斯，他们在高位卖出。他们把橙汁卖给那些认为价格还会继续涨得更高的人。
that. Yeah, it's a really tricky fine point here, but I'm just gonna out and out say this. You don't have to own any orange juice in order to sell it because I know it's weird. They are selling a promise. They're selling, they're saying, I will promise to deliver you orange juice in April. That was the April part of that. And you will pay me this large amount of money sometime in the future. Our heroes have until then to find some cheap orange juice
对，这里有一个非常微妙的精细点，但我直截了当地说吧。你根本不需要手里真有橙汁就能把它卖出去，我知道这听起来很诡异。他们卖的是一种承诺。他们在卖出，他们在说：“我承诺在四月份交付给你橙汁。”这就是那句台词里“四月”的意思。而你将在未来的某个时间付给我一大笔钱。我们的主角有时间去找到便宜的橙汁，
and to fulfill their contracts. You've heard of the old saying like, buy low and sell high. Yes, that one I know. It turns out though, and this is the key to short selling. The key to the entire movie is you can do it the other way. You can sell high first and then turn around quickly and buy low. Make a ton of money. And our heroes are about to get to buy extremely low because the crop report, the real crop report, is about to come out. And it's kind of crazy because everyone on the training floor just stops and looks at the TV.
来兑现他们的合同。你听说过那句老话吗，“低买高卖”。对，那个我知道。不过事实证明，这也是卖空的精髓所在。整部电影的关键就在于，你可以反着来。你可以先高价卖出，然后立刻转过头去低价买入。赚它个盆满钵满。而我们的主角们马上就要以极低的价格买入了，因为农作物报告，真正的农作物报告，马上就要公布了。而且这疯狂的一幕是，交易大厅里的所有人都停下了手中的活，齐刷刷地盯着电视屏幕。
Ladies and gentlemen, the orange crop estimates for the next year. And I mean, this is obviously a Hollywood moment. Traitors don't really just stare at the TV and there's not a long awkward pause while the Secretary of Agriculture comes on. This is dramatic tension, Robert. I think he's putting on his glasses and everything. After calculating the estimates from various orange producing states, we have concluded the following.
女士们先生们，接下来一年的橙子收成预估报告。我的意思是，这显然是一个好莱坞式的戏剧时刻。现实中的交易员才不会仅仅盯着电视，而且农业部长登场时也不会出现那种漫长而尴尬的暂停。这是戏剧张力，罗曼。我觉得他还特意戴上了眼镜什么的。在计算了各个产橙州的预估数据后，我们得出以下结论。
The cold winter has apparently not affected the orange harvest. That sound you hear is a bunch of people who just realize that they bet the wrong way. That there is no shortage, that the dukes, and everyone who bought with them, including Adam's dad, now own a lot of very expensive orange juice, way too expensive. And now that the real crop report is out, the price is drop-ins, 102, 96, it's plunging to 72, 64.
寒冷的冬天显然没有对橙子的收成产生影响。你听到的那个声音，是一群刚刚意识到自己押错方向的人发出的哀叹。他们意识到根本没有短缺，杜克兄弟以及所有跟着他们一起买入的人——包括亚当的爸爸——现在手里都攥着一大堆价格极其昂贵、贵得离谱的橙汁。而现在，真正的农作物报告一出，价格开始暴跌：1.02美元、0.96美元，一路狂泻到0.72美元、0.64美元。
Everyone who bought high now wants to sell and cut their losses, and that's driving the price down even further. It's now at 46. And remember, our heroes knew this was going to happen. They sold a ton of orange juice at a crazy high price and now the entire trading floor, including the Duke brothers. The entire floor is begging to sell them orange juice for crazy cheap. to sell them orange juice for crazy cheap. Oh, no! Oh, no!
所有曾经高价买入的人现在都想赶紧抛售、割肉止损，这反过来又把价格进一步向下推。价格现在跌到了0.46美元。记住，我们的主角早就知道会这样。他们在极高的价位卖出了大量的橙汁，而现在整个交易大厅，包括杜克兄弟在内，整个交易大厅的人都在哀求他们以白菜价把橙汁卖给自己。以白菜价把橙汁卖给自己。不！不！
So, man! Now, here's where a hero sit as the chaos clears. Other people have promised to buy orange juice from them. At a price as high as 142 a pound, 142. And now minutes later, people are promising to sell orange juice to them as cheap as 29 cents a pound. Billy Ray and Lewis get to pocket the difference. It is an epic move, probably a significantly bigger one day move than the orange juice market
所以，伙计们！随着混乱渐渐平息，我们的主角们就这样坐在那里。其他人承诺以高达每磅1.42美元的价格向他们购买橙汁，价格高达1.42美元。而几分钟后，人们却承诺以低至每磅29美分的价格向他们兜售橙汁。比利·雷和路易斯把这中间的差价全揣进了兜里。这是一次史诗级的操作，很可能是橙汁市场有史以来单日最大的一次行情反转。
has ever had in its entire history. It's purely fictional move, but enough to enable these guys to retire handsomely. We had our commodities guys watch this pretty closely, but it's hard to estimate just how much money, Billy Ray, and Lewis made on this scam. We see the price of orange juice futures, but not how many contracts. All we know at the end of the movie is that the Duke brothers,
纯粹是一个虚构的操作，但足以让这些家伙赚得盆满钵满，风风光光地退休。我们让大宗商品专家们非常仔细地观看了这一段，但很难估算出比利·雷和路易斯在这个骗局中到底赚了多少钱。我们看到了橙汁期货的价格，但不知道具体的合同数量。我们只知道在电影结尾时，杜克兄弟，
they are bankrupt. Yeah, they bought all of that orange juice. What it was at crazy high prices, they bought high. And if and when they sell it, it's gonna be at terribly low prices. They did the opposite of what you need to do to make money in the market. They lost nearly $400 million, and the way trading works are here is probably pocketed most of that money, and as for our villains, the dukes, they get their come-up ends at the
他们破产了。对，他们以疯狂的高价买入了所有那些橙汁，他们高买低卖了。如果真要卖出去的话，他们只能以极低的价格抛售。他们的做法完全违背了在市场上赚钱的法则。他们亏损了将近4亿美元，而按照交易运作的逻辑，我们的主角很可能把这笔钱的大部分都揣进了腰包。至于我们的反派杜克兄弟，他们在交易日结束时迎来了他们的下场。
end of trading day. It turns out they borrowed a lot of that money they just lost. at the end of trading day. AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH three hundred ninety four million dollars in cash. I'm sorry boys. Put the Duke brothers seats on the exchange up for sale at once. Seize all assets of Duke and Duke commodities brokers as well as all personal holdings up Randolph and Mortimer Duke. And this dramatic crazy, clearly Hollywood ending, the bad guys lose everything. They get booted out of their rich positions in the market. This really happens sometimes, according to Tom. He says people would borrow money, bet it all on a market move, and when it went the opposite
原来他们亏掉的这大笔钱里，有很多都是借来的。在交易日结束时。啊——！（尖叫声）三亿九千四百万美元的现金。对不起了，小伙子们。立刻把杜克兄弟在交易所的席位拿去拍卖。查封杜克父子大宗商品经纪公司的所有资产，以及兰道夫·杜克和莫蒂默·杜克的全部个人财产。在这个戏剧性、疯狂、显然好莱坞式的结局中，坏人失去了一切。他们被赶出了他们在市场上的显赫位置。据汤姆所说，现实中这种情况有时确实会发生。他说，有人会借钱，把全部身家押在某次市场行情上，而当市场走势完全相反时，
direction, they had to pay up. Most clearing houses had people who were referred to as legbreakers. They weren't like a real mobster, legbreakers, but they were the ones who would say, all right, you know, time to pony up, all right, well, you know, we want your house, we want your IRA. It would happen right there on the floor. That's a little over dramatized, but it would happen that day or the next day, you know, there wouldn't be much of a time lag.
他们就必须自掏腰包把窟窿补上。大多数清算所里都有被称为“断腿者”的人。他们虽然不像真正的黑帮打手那样残暴，但他们就是那些会说：“好了，你知道的，该付钱了，好了，你知道的，我们看中你的房子了，我们看中你的退休金账户了”的人。这一切当时就会直接在交易大厅里发生。这虽然有点戏剧夸张，但在当天或第二天确实就会发生，你知道的，中间不会有什么时间差。
He said there's one more unrealistic thing, at least in today's world. Computer trading took over the commodities market. That climactic scene, if they remade the movie today, it would sound a lot like this. It's all people staring at screens today. This kind of obvious drama is gone from the business. It would be a very quiet climactic scene. The Duke brothers would be on their own private hell, you know, looking at a computer screen,
他说，还有一点非常不切实际，至少在当今的世界是这样。计算机交易接管了大宗商品市场。那场高潮迭起的戏，如果今天重拍这部电影，听起来大概会是这个样子。如今所有人都是盯着屏幕看。这种显而易见的戏剧性场面已经从这个行业中消失了。那会是一场非常安静的高潮戏。杜克兄弟会坐在他们自己的私人炼狱里，你知道的，盯着电脑屏幕，
head beret in their hands. Tom Peronis says, and this makes me very happy, that people still bring up the movie when he says he trades in orange juice futures, and even among his fellow traders, there's a sort of reverence for the movie, that lines from the script have become part of the lingo of commodities trading. Definitely some of these lines have become stock phrases like over the years, especially in the OJ market, I've heard people say like Sel Mortimer, Sel Mortimer, Duke and Duke is buying.
双手抱头。汤姆·皮罗尼斯说——这让我感到非常高兴——每当他提到自己从事橙汁期货交易时，人们还是会提起这部电影，甚至在他的同行之中，对这部电影也有一种近乎崇敬的态度，以至于剧本里的台词都成了大宗商品交易圈的行话。毫无疑问，多年来，其中的一些台词已经成了常用语，尤其是在橙汁市场上，我经常听到有人喊：“卖掉莫蒂默！卖掉莫蒂默！杜克兄弟在买入！”
I've heard that too many times to count. Yeah, it's definitely become part of the OJ lore. Well, there wasn't much OJ lore to add to it. That's right. There's not much OJ lore in the first place, but the stuff from trading places makes up a significant chunk of it. Hmm. You know what I mean? I always assumed that this whole scam was illegal. Our hero's basically stole inside information.
这种话我听过无数次了。对，它绝对已经成了橙汁交易圈传说的一部分。好吧，本来也没多少橙汁传说可以补充。没错。橙汁本来就没什么传说，但《颠倒乾坤》里的这些桥段构成了其中相当大的一块。嗯。你知道我的意思吗？我一直以为整个这个骗局是非法的。我们的主角基本上是盗取了内幕消息。
They essentially stole the crop report. And they took all this money, not just from the dukes, but from everyone in the market. And at the end, they're sitting on a Caribbean beach. And I thought, oh, they're on the run from the law. But it turns out, at the time, insider trading was not strictly illegal in the commodities market. And that kind of makes sense because there's so many people involved. If you are a farmer trading corn, you have this ultimate inside information about corn and everyone in the agriculture business, that's a little something that someone else doesn't. But it's the part where they steal the crop report, that seems way way over the line.
他们实质上偷走了农作物报告。他们卷走了所有的钱，不仅是从杜克兄弟那里，还是从市场上的所有人那里。而到了结尾，他们正舒舒服服地坐在加勒比海的海滩上。我想，哦，他们这是在逃避法律制裁呢。但事实证明，在当时，内幕消息在大宗商品市场上并不算严格意义上的违法。这其实也说得过去，因为涉及的人实在太多了。如果你是一个交易玉米的农户，你本身就掌握着关于玉米的终极内幕消息，而农业行的每个人，都或多或少掌握着别人不知道的信息。但他们偷取农作物报告的那一部分，看起来确实远远越界了。
Yeah, setting aside the actual theft of the suitcase, which happens in a movie, you shouldn't steal it. Which is illegal. Every respect. You should not steal things. But the actual way in which they made money with stolen information, it turns out that was legal. And I learned this because when Congress was coming up with the banking reform law, Dodd-Frank in 2010, they were debating what should be in the bill and not and they came up with a special provision. It's something that the chair
对，抛开电影里实际潜入行窃的桥段不谈——在现实中你可不应该去偷东西。那是违法的。从各方面来说。你不应该去偷东西。但他们利用偷来的信息赚钱的实际方式，事后证明竟然是合法的。我之所以知道这一点，是因为国会在2010年制定银行改革法案《多德-弗兰克法案》时，他们一直在争论法案里该包含什么、不该包含什么，于是他们专门加入了一条特殊条款。这是商品期货交易委员会
of the Commodity's Future Trading Commission, Gary Gensler, he said, we need this thing. It is called the Eddie Murphy Rule, a rule that will make what happened to trading places illegal. And it made it in. It's Dodd-Frank Section 746, which basically says that a federal employee can't leak information about the price of a commodity, so that someone can make money off of it. And a person who gets that leaked information,
主席加里·根斯勒提出的一项要求，他说：“我们需要这个条款。”这就是所谓的“艾迪·墨菲法则”，正是这条规则让《颠倒乾坤》里发生的事情变成了违法行为。而且它真的被写进了法案。这就是《多德-弗兰克法案》第746条，大意是联邦雇员不得泄露关于大宗商品价格的信息，以免别人利用它牟利。而获取了这些泄露信息的人，
they can't use that to make money off of the market. Yeah, Gensel said that before this rule went into effect, what Eddie Murphy, Gilly Ray Valentine, and Dan Acquired, Louis Winthrop III, what they did, misappropriate information, and then use it to corner the orange juice market, what they did was not actually illegal. They got away with it.
也不能利用它在市场上谋取利益。对，根斯勒曾说过，在这个规则出台之前，艾迪·墨菲饰演的比利·雷·瓦伦丁和丹·艾克罗伊德饰演的小路易斯·温索普当年的所作所为——也就是挪用信息，然后利用它来操纵橙汁市场——在当时其实并不违法。他们居然就这么逃脱了法律的制裁。
They got away with it! Oh, that makes me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but you always catch up with us online at 99%invisible.org. The OTPRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们竟然逃脱了制裁！哦，这可真是……我是罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW 以及旧金山美国建筑师学会联合制作的项目。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并关注我们的节目。我在推特上的账号是 @RomanMars，不过你随时可以在我们的官网上收听往期节目：99%invisible.org。OTP-RX。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。